during that postseason you had a moment
against the Padres probably one of your
most embarrassing moments tell me about
it I had a root canal Crown gets
infected and I talked to the doctor and
my molar's killing me man we'll send you
some antibiotics the only problem is
diarrhea is a side effect so I'm in The
Dugout we're on defense I think we
punched out Manny to get out of the
inning and I let go of it
those emotions make my body like push a
little Fork comes out I'm like oh I
think I just
I had to lead off the inning that was
the third out there was no time I got a
plate I punched out in three pitches
against Garrett Richards and I go
running upstairs to this point I haven't
realized we're wearing white yet
I just knew I did but I was a gosh I got
two pairs of Sliders they'll hold up put
the sliders to the side sure enough the
same stain that is on my sliders was on
the white pants on National Television
dude wife's heard about it we got a deal
done and I got a little bit of cash you
got paid for pooping in your own pants
happens man